hello friends I'm Ilana and welcome to
my channel where today I'm really
self-conscious about everything I'm
looking at because you can all see it
today I'm using a Toby eye tracker oh I
hate it there's something very weird
about how self-conscious you get when an
eye tracker is being used because you
never think about what you're looking at
until suddenly everyone can see your
line of sight it's something that you're
so used to being so private that
suddenly gets taken away from you like
why do I keep looking at this girl I
don't even know why I keep looking at
her and then it's a when it's a woman I
look up there and then I keep looking at
this dude oh it's it's I already hate
that i broadcasting this so today I'm
doing an eye tracker challenge a friend
sent me a list of things to look up on
the website giffy I have it starts with
dogs which I guess means you'll see what
kind of dogs I find cute again because I
don't really have a say of what I look
at that's just my first response I get
to show you before I choose it's really
strange um and then it gets into
phosphate and then down the bottom of
the list is sexy pink and BDSM so this
one's gonna get demonetised also I'm
sick so my voice is a little deeper than
normal but let's just let's get started
we're putting in dogs all right I'm
gonna close my eyes I'm not looking at
the screen right now and I just open it
that checks out I do like that kind of
dog oh we've got all those puppies it
was because there wasn't the face that
caught my oh I don't like that
that's awful I don't like any of who's
using these if they let's just scroll a
bit
I think I'm yep I like the big dogs
generally and I think the gifts that
have movement I just naturally catching
my eye okay so that's an example of how
it works
dogs is not that much of an interesting
one on this website
cuz it's mostly hot trash memes next up
is anime
open well I didn't even know anime
that's from that's that's just copy okay
yep
yep it's mostly uh I Death Note yeah
Dragonball checks out Oh Pikachu all
right yeah I'm into that
I feel like again I'm for these I'm
mostly looking at the things that are
the best animated ah yes Ghibli love
that squad of squad
I guess I'm also looking at the things I
recognize well I think I looked at that
one because I thought it was sexual my
brain went right there yep what are they
doing
oh they're laughing really hard okay my
bad no more squirtle it is totally
drawing my eyes to things that I
recognize that's that's that's what it
is
so it's either things that have a lot of
movement things I think is sexual which
I would not have thought that my brain
was that tuned to pay attention to and
things I recognized more more Ghibli
they're good stuff next we have fast
food closing my eyes scroll in a little
bit okay yep you go went straight for
the Nuggets didn't she okay that's all
B's I've never had that that looks Bri
good dang nope not interested in that
because I think I saw some pizza that
mac and cheese mmm that's what got it
Burger King not bad not bad well no I'm
just looking at a girl are these one of
those like Super Bowl ads they do or is
this a parody from some kind of TV show
I call it hide what I'm looking at it's
so bad I'm so sorry I didn't mean to
objectify you look how stressed out my
eyes on now oh okay she naked
alright hmm that's a thing you decided
to make again with the sexual stuff I
feel like you don't even think about it
it just happens like why did I I think
faces do it for me as well alright what
are you doing
you heathen that's such a waste of pizza
that [ __ ] looks good mm-hmm nice
glistening sausages yep alright moving
on
cute hell yeah sounds good okay
Strega Becca oh I get always sleepy boys
you know that's a lot all right you know
this is the best
yeah oh that's good pet that one got
confused on with my eyes I think is in
my head my eyes looking at it - nose
yeah maybe that's right mmhmm yeah I
relate to that Brooke loves a good auto
oh man all very cute okay next up we
have hot guys all right
okay well yeah makes sense that that
would be what would happen here okay I'm
scared to look anywhere else he looks
like Jake Gyllenhaal nice pecs
oh that's two men kissing okay keep
scrolling no it's Chris Pratt what he
was fat okay I'm not I'm not attracted
to this dude at all I think again
probably because his face was why my
brain went for that a lot of leonato huh
Leanna there's some naked dudes yep I
mean yeah checks out all right I wasn't
looking at that dude's dick I swear I
was looking at this dude's face the eye
tracker was slightly wrong I promise you
I was looking at the bottom dudes face
and not the top I saw where to go okay
all right next one is hot girls what
could go wrong all right
damn dude you buff as hell that's crazy
okay I don't know who that is
I guess yeah I just looking at cleavage
mount that's yep noticeable okay [ __ ] oh
it's the worst it can't help but
objectify people and it feels bad man
it's just okay that's someone's face
that's good that's better Megan Fox well
I don't know what you want me to do [ __ ]
I'm a human okay there's less titty here
nope but I still found it immediately is
that Kim Kardashian yep Rihanna's babe
this girl's with a horse nice feathers
you have they're weird dude okay I
figure her name what is it of the from
the community she's Annie
I don't remember sis name I'm sorry
sweetheart mm-hmm okay are you going
down on her no okay
okay got it there's a lot of this dude
talking about being a hot girl for some
reason um well I'm friends with her
that's I don't feel good about any
effect [ __ ] okay now we're moving on I
don't know why I think it's gonna get
any better when I type in the word sexy
there's no way this is gonna get better
it's gonna be worse
all right he started off by looking at
someone's shoes Ilana good work well
yeah it's Robert Downey jr. considered
sexy I don't know just keep looking at
that though it's safe
no thank you I always found this image
of Angelina Jolie it to be really funny
because she does not look natural doing
that with her hair she looks like she's
trying extremely hard and it's supposed
to be like peak sexy but no that doesn't
look natural love No all right well well
I'm okay
I don't know why I would look at that
that's inherently supposed to be
appealing to men right why does that get
the I'm looking at the pipe uh citizens
reference excellent oh hello
okay yeah and not bad not bad what is
that like we fit training you're using a
whole hood but why she's pretty I don't
feel like this well it's gonna say I
don't feel like this has been too bad no
he's cute
hello sir cuz I'm looking at things that
aren't sexual as well as you know the
half naked dancing women
that's just anime it's called hentai you
know not that she's just cute is that
marina Co no I don't think so
alright I don't feel like I did that
badly here but y'all definitely caught
me looking at some titties and some
dudes biceps little chests mostly yeah
definitely mostly chests yeah that's my
bad same for both sexes though I don't
discriminate between genders I'm looking
at his chest I'm looking at her chest
I'm just enjoying everybody's titties
it's not a big deal okay next up we have
dink I don't know if if he's gonna have
pink guess it does
okay girls kissing this is not this is
mostly whoever this is who is eating no
this seems pretty tape this is not what
you wanted from the word kick I don't
think boy how did you how is this oh
well that's kinky but not what Jesus
Christ oh that's one of the worst things
I've ever seen
Oh God okay not that many kinks though
okay all right
kink is fine you know I survived a BDSM
Oh yep Fifty Shades of Grey is gonna be
in there I suppose
closing my eyes opening it again okay
that's just a picture of Miley Cyrus
with some very large eyelashes well it's
not that much of a canker is it just
someone wearing a body suit still
looking at men want are you okay mol
fifty Shades of Grey
whips whatever oh okay okay
man people on the Internet
shall be internetting huh what a lady
Gaga in here is that from telephone I
don't know what music video that is that
she does that there's just some whips
some some some leather business oh
that's horrific
why would you do it to that file like my
daughter
well Jesse oh well he's actually pretty
ripped I've only seen a bit of one of
those movies and I was pretty drunk all
right not but hey Pyramid Head why'd it
take me that long
notice that I'm a fake gamer okay so
I've just texted my friend that I
thought that sexy and King can be
jeaious and we're actually too easy so
he has suggested that instead I put it
in Google what could go wrong well I
mean it's all pretty similar
disproportionate amount of women here
versus men well I always look at people
kissing I wonder why it's also just not
that interesting you're mostly just like
looking at people in bikinis and [ __ ]
it's fine all right
yep Hawkgirl selfie in mirror sure was a
side boob I can't not look at it maybe
I'm getting better at it
maybe sexy is just not as a universal as
we all thought maybe that's what it is
she's pretty Ilana all right you guys I
think that's it for me if you have any
ideas for how to use the eye tracker let
me know it has shifted slightly which i
think is why my eyeline has gone a
little bit off
it's just moved on the stand I have it
on which is Obama but this is really
just be testing it out and showing you
guys how weird it is to have everyone
else have the ability to see while
you're looking it's so like invasive in
a really strange way you fully just get
insecure about a thing that you never
would have even thought to be insecure
about before it's so so so weird but
yeah that's it for me today everyone I
am sick so I don't know when I'll make
another video hopefully sometime next
week but I'm trying not to overdo it
right now so I hope you understand I'll
see you guys next time